hello and welcome once again yet again
to Android design in action as always
I'm Roman Nurik hey guys my name's Adam
Kush and hi my name is Nick butcher and
Nick is joining us from Mountain View
today not rainy London since he's
actually visiting the the core Android
developer relations team out in Mountain
View Nicky I was Mountain View I'm in
San Francisco right now my hotel bedroom
it's like 7:00 a.m. nice well thanks for
joining so early in the morning rank so
today's episode of Android design in
action is we're gonna talk about
newsreaders we're not gonna look at any
specific apps since we're kind of still
kind of figuring out how we approach
nominations for apps that want to get
some redesigns we will be talking about
kind of hypothetical stuff today for
newsreaders and then we'll jump into
units of measures specifically density
independent pixels as well as some some
layout grids and pixel grids and all
sorts of fun stuff like that with that
shall we get started
so alright so let's talk about
newsreaders so previously on Android
design in action I think a few months
ago maybe in January we did a actually
we did an episode on iterative
improvements basically starting from a
very bare-bones newsreader type app you
know basically had a list of bacon very
bacony articles and a detailed section
that let you kind of view the details or
or read that article and we figured you
know why not just kind of use that as a
starting point and and see how we can
improve on the the reading experience
from there so here are some some slides
from the last episode of Android design
in action and you know you can see that
you have kind of this list of articles
on the left you know your news items and
then on a tablet of course you have this
multi pane UI where you have the list of
articles on the left and then your
details on the right and then on the
phone you just have you know your
details
usually a photo you know a title and
obviously the meat of the article which
is you know a big black text
yes j2i of a meet of the already in real
I didn't even I set up on any realize it
but yes exactly so and then we also did
some alternatives where you know let's
say you really want to focus on the
photos you know here are some things you
can do you can you can make the photo
kind of full-bleed and let the article
of the text be kind of an overlay on top
of that and there are a couple of things
that we talked about including you know
background protection was great with
dark gradients and things of that nature
so these are just two of the
presentations that we that we threw
together for details so today I wanted
to talk about I guess different or
alternative presentations of these
things as well as enhancements kind of I
guess further iterative improvements on
this experience that can really make
news reading a pleasure so let's jump
into some of those the first is and this
is actually you know kind of a power
user feature probably should have save
this for last but you know and back with
Android 4.1 we we provided this kind of
new feature called expanded
notifications right so you have your
collapse notifications and then with a
two finger gesture you kind of pull down
to to expand the notification to see
more details with recent versions of
Android you can actually just use a
single finger kind of to swipe down if
there aren't that many notifications in
the list so one of the things that we're
thinking about is you know as you're
browsing a set of stories right as
you're browsing this list oftentimes you
know you want to get a little more you
don't want to necessarily read the
entire article or see everything you
just want to get a slightly larger
preview so you know there are a couple
of ways of doing that if that's of
interest to you and your news reader app
you know obviously you could have you
know a button within that list item like
a preview button you could potentially
have a go long press preview or sort of
a long press to show contextual action
bar and they could have a preview there
but you know we thought you know this is
kind of a maybe a power user thing you
know once you discover it you start
using it a little more so why not use a
power user user gesture so one way of
doing this is let's say you know you use
your two fingers to scroll down or
to swipe down on an article you would
you'd swipe down and then you start
seeing the preview so in this case it's
a video the video maybe even starts
playing inline automatically and this is
something that you can definitely do as
of Android 4.0 or actually even Android
3.0 actually now it's 4.0 that we had
this booklet I yeah yeah it's extra view
that the lets you basically play you
know video int or do lots of interesting
things inside of you know a graphical
object that's composed with the rest of
you know your window but the idea is
that you know you could do cool things
like play video in line you could you
know apply animations transitions to
video but you know here's one example of
where you can you know take video and
make it inline alternatively you know if
you just have text or a photo you can
kind of you know as you swipe down to
expand you could show the text obviously
you could show a photo maybe even
horizontally swipeable unless you know
you have another competing gesture for
horizontal swipe but it's just the idea
that you know sometimes a simple little
title that's probably a lip sized is
just not enough so so this is kind of
one way of doing that of alleviating
that absolutely fun power gesture I like
the use of it in the list context
because as you say horizontal swipe is
quite you know competing for a lot of
different gestures they're going on its
face at the moment so this is really
nice way to acts on a single list item
yeah it's really good for power users
but then for users that you know one of
brows normally it doesn't sort of
interfere with that flowy that they can
just tap and move into the article as
well right it's not like the only way of
exposing the content you can actually
just you know touch to get to the
content that's the primary gesture
involved there but for the parties have
discovered this may be a kind of
additional nice thing bootstraps on the
rich notification as well right it's pre
programs that show a similar amount of
content as you might be preparing
already it laying out for a rich
notification and then it builds on that
same gesture so you kind of bootstrap
the kind of interaction just cool as an
additional thing maybe to kind of hinted
at it at the gesture and this is
something that we talked about a while
ago with respect to dismiss right you
know when we swipe to dismiss you
sometimes but it's not necessarily a
very very discoverable gesture on its
own but let's say you kind of also
provide the ability to long press
an object and then press the delete item
in the contextual action bar and it kind
of slides away that kind of hints subtly
that hey I can do that same thing with
my finger not necessarily just you
always use the delete action the
contextual action bar but I can actually
try this with my finger and it works so
in this case what you could do is you
know as these list items populate you
could kind of animate them in so start
with a larger size and then as they fall
into place they kind of like shrink into
the collapsed size just to hint that
there's actually more under each list
item and that you can get to it with
your two finger that's right but lots of
different things you can do here that
the basic point is you know make the
news browsing experience great not only
the news reading experience but the news
browsing experience along with in those
same along the same lines I guess you
know consider alternative presentations
for your collection right so when you
present a list of articles or I guess a
collection of articles since it's not
always a list you know consider ways to
make that a more richer you know
experience so one of the things that we
looked at in the past is pocket which
switches from you know on a phone it's a
list to on a 7-inch tablet it's a grid
to run a 10-inch tablet it's kind of
like a staggered grid where a single
cell can take multiple items or multiple
columns you know in that same vein how
can you make this a little more rich so
one of the alternatives obviously is you
know to make this you know full bleed or
basically almost full bleed photos and
just the text on top and in cases where
you don't have a you know photo you
could kind of use a standard background
like that this works really well for
very very graphically rich you know news
content pieces like it doesn't really
work so well for text but certainly if
you have lots of photos or videos this
is a good way of presenting it yeah one
of the core design principles is that
you know pictures of thoughts of them
words and then this is a excellent
demonstration of it if you have the
imagery then like you know shout about
it make it as big as you can yeah yeah
it's definitely frustrating when a news
app has really great imagery and then
they have timing look they even use this
ListView one and they have tiny little
images there so you know both of these
presentations look really nice yeah
tiny photos there's definitely a pet
peeve especially had tablets like such a
beautiful screen like a Nexus 10 right
beautiful screen and not using it to
show photos if you have really high res
photos is is kind of a missed
opportunity so in the side note to this
pattern is but oh and one of the things
I realized using this pattern is the use
of like a a zoom animation if you click
on with the tiles to retain context and
that makes it really easy to kind of you
know click on with those squares and it
zooms up so the picture becomes like you
know the whole screen and they're super
simple to build it's like two lines of
code record activity options and it
really will change your contact you
really kind of like have that link
witching where you came from why you
getting screen that's a good point okay
moving on the next thing we wanted to
talk about was the the very much
you know comment that are buzzed about
navigation drawer pattern so you know
what you could do is you know let's say
you have an app that has lots of
hierarchy what you could do is you could
have you know a spinner right you could
have a drill down list navigation where
basically you have like you know when
you first get to the app you have a list
of categories and then you touch the
category to get into the details of that
to see all the articles within that
category but you know what what we've
been using in some of our apps recently
and I'm sure you know all of you out
there now is this new pattern call that
we're calling the navigation drawer so
the navigation drawer is basically this
thing that kind of slides out from the
left it's also called the the sliding
menu or the flyin menu and it can work
really well where you have you know lots
of you know sibling sections it's really
good for it's really primarily for
navigation you work really well when you
have lots of adjacent you know sections
that don't really work well as tabs and
maybe they're kind of too heavy weight
for a spinner and you know the other
nice thing about the navigation sorry go
ahead snake oh sorry simply two men yes
well I think a spinner you kind of start
maxing out over at you know five six
seven items right mm-hmm so one of the
things that we were thinking about and
this is something that comes up
frequently is you know what if I have a
really really deep heavy hierarchy right
so I have you know 10 or 20 top-level
sections and then within each section I
have you know 10 sub sections or
something and this kind of if you're a
news organization you probably have this
you probably about it's pretty cold a
live course most news apps right yeah
and also sports leagues or
any sort of sports tracking you know you
have you know a bunch of different
leagues with different sub leagues and
and uh you know categorizations of
league it could be pretty heavyweight so
what we are thinking about is and this
is actually something that we've been
recommending is letting the user
customize so a good example of this is
currents google currents it has a list
of kind of top-level news categories
like you know sports and business and
things like that but then when within
each section you can actually customize
which news sources you use so we took
this one step further let's cust it
let's let the user customize the entire
Left pane right so the the navigation
drawer is is kind of quick access right
it's it's the top level of hierarchy
let's let's give the user the full
customization of that right so what you
see here is an example of what you could
do if you love these or to customize so
at the very top you see the users kind
of favorited or you know I guess
favorited sections with this customize
button that lets you change what's going
on there when you first open up the app
let's say you haven't used it yet you'd
probably just see customize or you just
see like you know some pre canned items
right and then below that like under you
know more news or etc etc you'd see kind
of the things that everybody should see
things like saved stories feature top
videos whatever it's really up to you
but at the very top is this kind of
heavily customizable section so let's
take a look at so this is pretty
straightforward but the more interesting
part is the actual customized screen so
when you press customize what do you see
this is an example of something you
could build so the first thing you want
to do and there's a couple of things
right you want to be able to this is
basically like list management right
you'll be able to delete items you want
to be able to reorder items make things
you know higher than others and you want
to obviously be able to add and search
for things so we've combined all of
those all of those different tasks into
a single UI so on the left you can
notice that you know you have the these
drag handles for reordering and we've
we've highlighted this before and
previous episodes of the show I think
the one I'm shopping with
or something like that and then you can
also you know remove items using the
standard kind of swipe to dismiss we
also talked about what we just mentioned
selector this miss may not be you know
super discoverable you can absolutely
also offer like contextual actions so if
I long press on like this search for
Android or long press on food and health
it'll select those items and I'll press
Delete you know get them out of the way
you should also support undo right so if
that does happen show the user the
option to undo what they did either
contextually in line with the item or as
that bottom bar that we've shown before
additionally you know another important
part of this is adding right you know
adding a topic we're searching for a
topic and this is where you know I think
the bulk of this UI you know it's
different from other current
interactions so the idea is that you
know you have a lot of hierarchy and you
know one of the best ways to to kind of
flatten hierarchy is through search
right so you can obviously let the user
you know drill down into different you
know levels of hierarchy and that can be
tedious but sometimes it's warranted so
for that you know you kind of would
always see this browse for more or
browse item so as soon as you kind of
give focus to this at a topic text field
you should see this kind of browse right
now but as soon as you start typing in
this text field it does a kind of a
global search across all of the
different categories and subcategories
and sub subcategories and basically very
very easily lets you find what you're
doing without having to drill down find
what you want without having to drill
down the other thing is I mean obviously
ranking is important here just a brief
note about ranking you know you want to
make sure that you know you you if you
do kind of use this kind of UI you wanna
make sure that you kind of rank deeper
matches higher than kind of lower level
mattress or higher level matches so like
if if you have something like sports and
then soccer if you're typing SOC it
should rank higher than like top social
stories associated with that is that
it's it's more pertinent it's more
detailed so you always want to show the
the more detailed information on time so
that's you know I had a very you know a
very very fast way of explaining this
that's roughly what this
works like it looks like because of any
other suggestions or other ways in which
you can you know potentially expose is
kind of large hierarchy well just you
come into earlier on but I think in the
shocking episode we did a while back you
had a really interesting presentation an
alternative to this way instead of
having the search you had like a list of
articles you had a little view I client
muted like table today
so there will be an alternative
presentation if you didn't have such a
very very deep hierarchy and you wanted
to be able to present them to use it to
the user to kind of give them the you
know the the knowledge of what that is
available what I really like about this
presentation with the search is not only
is it kind of you know easier to
navigate a very large structure it also
makes it feel more like mine the idea of
like presenting me some you know given
list and then toggling it you know it's
very much kind of here's the things
available to you whereas searches like
here's the things like one it's kind of
a bit more personal to me I like it and
I also very much like the customize
behavior I think too many people see
navigation as a way to dump every you
know to advertise every single feature
the app offers but having this very very
small list makes it again more relevant
so that you know Huck's back to our
design principles show me only what I
need when I need it and which I really
really like yeah it's just the way to
kind of combat very heavy navigation
drawers and anytime you have navigation
you want to make it as light as possible
right you don't overburden the user with
stuff that they have to think about
before they actually get to their
content right so this is just you know
one of the easy ways of doing that I
think when everyone's using a news app
you never really not all the sections
are relevant to you so it's just really
nice to have to bubble them up quickly
and if hierarchy is really really deep
and really broad then it's just hard to
find those those items that you want to
add into your favorites actually haven't
seen that many news apps that really
really nailed that
that's a flow of adding different topics
to your favorites list mm-hmm just a
couple notes again on the slide and ROI
I know we talked about it's quite a lot
in our design hangout to that just while
we're here a couple of things I really
like about this and as you can see that
as the drawer opens we changed the
screen title and drop the up caret and
and also drop that refresh icon so it's
really important that you know you keep
the action bar in place but you can die
now
via justice options to make it
appropriate so when you have your major
navigation in sections open and I think
another great thing talking about that
two fingers swipe down it's because
we're not reserving a horizontal Josh
gesture on the list view type screen it
means you could do a whole Content swipe
to open this drawer so it makes the
drawer that much more discoverable so
you don't have to just do an edge type
swipe you can swipe from anywhere
horizontally within the page and find
the drawer which is going to help users
get to know that we should push on
waiver anyway yeah that clock is
probably wrong okay so let's we talked
about that very quickly I wanted to talk
about some very last items here so the
other thing you want to obviously
optimize is the article reading
experience you know there's you know one
of the ways in which you could look at
this is there's a beginning of the
article a middle of the article where
you're kind of focusing on the content
and then the end of the article where
you're kind of winding down so the
beginning of the article you want to you
know see everything you wanna you know
see the action bar you want to see you
know the title potentially share options
if like immediately want to share
something but once you start you know
reading once you start scrolling down
one of the things you could do is you
can actually first of all go into
lights-out mode where the status bar
navigation bar kind of get into a dim
state and potentially the action bar can
you know hide right and this is kind of
similar to the quick return pattern
where you know you start scrolling down
maybe you know a few hundred pixels or
so or a few hundred dips and the action
bar kind of slides out of the way for
you and then as soon as you start
scrolling back up you may be kind of
going you know backwards you may want to
you know see other options so you can
show the action bar again this could
also be coupled with you know touch to
to toggle the action bar so lots of
different things you can do here but the
idea is that if a user doesn't really
care about the actions in the kind of in
that specific context of reading the
text you know you don't necessarily need
to show it always and then once you get
to the end of the article the action bar
should slide back in because it has that
kind of key share action and you see
here the presentation with the share
action provider that gives you the kind
of the most frequently used or most
recently used shared destination and
then you also see things like you know
the comments obviously
or in in this section you see here we
kind of expose a little bit of that
hierarchy and then related stories and
the idea here is you know the only real
point here is that you don't want to
have the entire experience and there you
know if there are things that the user
can really benefit from at the end of
this detail item you know related items
or other things expose them right there
so that they don't have to press back
right the best experience is when you
don't actually have to press back or up
or anything it's just kind of a
continual flow right you kind of flow
through the app so definitely consider
doing this if you have you know the
opportunity to expose deleted items and
things like that before we jump into the
next section any last comments on
newsreaders or anything
no you should get going
all right let's do it so let's jump into
units of measure
Adam Nick do you guys want to take on
unit to measure sure so and screen
variations go ahead yeah absolutely so
when we're talking about you know design
for Android in the welfare of different
screens out there and there's you know a
few things you have to think about when
you talk about different types of screen
and the one that most people tend to
lock onto is resolution right it's a
very well understood you know measure
especially coming from the desktop world
but when we're talking about mobile
where devices have this vastly different
you know densities of screen resolution
actually turns out to be not that you
know useful number in its kind of raw
numbers like if you look at a you know
to tablets to 10-inch tablets like the
Motorola Xoom and the Nexus 10 and have
vastly different resolutions four times
the number of pixels the Nexus 10 but
they're pretty much very similar screens
when you're going to design you know
content is going to go on to it right so
it turns out the resolution isn't as
interesting as talking about size and
density so luckily Android has embraced
this from the very start and we have
this concept this kind of abstraction
layer if you want called this density
independent pixel and so what this is as
we said here on the slide is a density
independent pixel or DP or just
generally sake dip and a dip is a unit
of measure which keeps things physically
the same size across various different
screens so you know things are certain
you know size is like a finger is like
77 millimeters big on average or
something like that so you want to size
your user interface element so that kind
of
roughly the same fiscal size across
devices so that they're easy to tap easy
to see and so forth so by using and this
this kind of like fake size you know
this dip and you don't have to worry
about how many pixels the screen
actually you know lights up to display
it you just kind of slide it so this
right kind of you know virtual size and
the screen will take care of it so one
thing I wanted to mention real quick is
that you know the core takeaway I think
from the rest of this if you're if
you're gonna take one thing away is that
you know as somebody that's working with
layout or as something that's working
with interaction design just forget
about pixels like pixels don't matter
right for visual design pixels matter
but for layout design interaction design
pixels just don't matter because dips
are kind of the way in which you kind of
make this entire world of designing for
different densities sane yeah we'll pick
up on that it's kind of you control you
kind of sacrifice a little bit of like
precise control in order for sanity for
dealing with this vast array of
different devices out there and so yeah
in the example here we've shown you have
a xhdpi device which might you know use
four hundred pixels to display an item
and a mdpi device which might actually
use 200 pixels but they're both the same
physical size as 200 different measure
other as we showed the wrong device in
that vision clothing yet the zoom is a
device that's mdpi so we've got a nexus
10 there we see which is actually
exception the Nexus S is hdpi in that
xhdpi but just forget about it right
let's move to next slide I'm calculating
do any you know talk about Kalkadoon
that's yeah so the the sort of baseline
dip value is is what we call em dpi or
160 160 dpi so this is sort of equation
they can use to calculate
pixels and dips and the sort of
conversion between them all so you can
basically take the DPI of a device so it
may be 160 but it could be something
else it could for example would be you
know HTTP io x HTTP I you divide it by
the baseline which is 160 and then that
gives you your ratio of pixels to two
dips so so just just so I don't know if
I fumbled it any wording there but don't
forget this DPI and this dip so they're
very closely related you know one is the
actual density of the device
the other is these dip units that we're
talking about so yes that's why I do PPI
is as I got dots per inch or PPI pixels
per inch and then you have dips which is
density in the pinnacle so I think we've
got some sample calculations here so
this mean sorry is to hammer this home
yeah I guess we got to be pretty fast
here so of course if the DPI of the
device is 160 which is the standard then
one pixel equals one dip straight
forward
if the density that ice is 320 so double
the sort of standard baseline of 160
then one dear pool equate to 2 pixels
yeah if you're coming from an iOS world
that's kind of similar to like the rest
of that is like act 2 X is IR xhdpi
right yeah so just you know one example
you know this is actually something that
the Wii best at anytime we've we've
talked about dips and presentations
we've we've asked this question so if
you look at the Nexus 7 screen
resolution 1280 by 800 right it's
actually the same as the Motorola Xoom
screen resolution 1280 by 800 and very
similar to the Galaxy Nexus and the
Nexus 4 is screen resolution 1280 by
something 768 720 but it's dip
resolution is very different so if you
you know plug in these values that the
fact that Nexus 7 is 213 dpi and 1280 by
800 you'll actually find that it's dip
resolution is 960 are roughly 960 by 600
dips and that kind of helps you figure
out you know how much content will fit
into this space right screen real estate
is really available for you to work with
you yeah so when you think about screen
real estate like definitely don't think
in pixels thinking dips okay so yes
Nexus 7 about 960 by 600 dips and if
you're doing any sort of development a
lot of our qualifiers like smallest with
width and height a lot of the resource
qualifiers that you use are based on
this resolution not the pixel resolution
so make sure that you use this
resolution when looking at the resolute
or the screen real estate available on a
device
so with grids you just briefly talk
about some of the grids that you should
be using when you're doing layout so
once you you know kind of are in this
world of dips you know after that you
kind of need to start thinking about
laying out your elements so obviously on
on Android you want to make sure that
you use you know constraint based
layouts so you know don't say this
should be exactly 200 dips or this
should be exactly 300 and that'll you
know roughly fill the space make sure
that you're using things like this
should be 20% of the screen or 20% of
the available real estate and then you
know make sure that you're using
straight base layout layout as well like
this should be to the right of this and
there should be below that but also you
know you want to use some basic sizes so
to the things that we generally
recommend using and to the things that
we document on developer that enter that
comma flash design are our 48 dip rhythm
which basically says that you know
roughly both vertically and horizontally
you should try to you know structure
items around you know 48 dips and width
and height especially touch target touch
targets the minimum size should really
be 48 dips but you know 48 dips 96 dips
multiples of 48 things like that work
well but with with the things like
spacing and margins and padding you want
to try to use a forever feel like a four
dip grid so what that means is that you
know the very smallest size or amount of
space between two items should be about
four dips or zero right if it's it's
completely flush but also it means that
you should use you know multiples of
four as things like margins you know so
the margins around your screen should be
you know 16 dips or 32 dips and then in
some cases you know you want to use like
eight dip spacers so you know what I
generally do as a designer is I use you
know 4 dips very rarely I use mostly
either 0 8 or 16 as my primary you know
of padding's and then on tablets I
actually used larger ones select 16 or
32 or things like that so in general you
know think in terms of multiples of 4
and then think about this 48 deeper than
where everything should really just
align to you know multiples of 48 in a
perfect world I never even picked up on
it but I love the system you I will use
this 48 it rhythm so that you know if
you've got software navigation like on a
nexus 4 we have the
and home buttons at one that's 48 tips
hire a the action bars 48 dips hi so
kind of you know falling into the rhythm
of this layout means your your app will
kind of fit in with the rhythm of the
page you know kind of Gestalt principles
yeah alright let's move on
so you're just an example of some of our
layouts and Nicki want to talk about the
red lines yeah so as you were saying
earlier when you're talking about layout
you talking about you know what you're
gonna put on a page you want to forget
about physical pixels and you want to
work in dips as I say you want to
prepare a layout for like a 10-inch type
device you know that size of screen then
you don't want to think about the raw
pixels you want to you know create your
canvas the all-union using an
illustrator or photoshop or fireworks or
whatever it might be to the dip size and
you know work at this baseline
resolution tip size so then when you do
your layout like the red line like we're
showing here the items like one pixel
therefore translates straight into one
dip so it's really really easy to do
your layout at this resolution and then
communicate that to your developers you
know hand them these red lines and show
them that these are the sizes and dips
that things need to clean it also works
well with like redlining tools there are
some tools for fireworks like inspector
or suspect there's some like that that
actually create these red lines for you
not these exact ones but the good thing
is that if you work with one pixel
equals one death and that baseline
density then it kind of uses the correct
values so you have to do any sort of
like doubling or halving or anything
yeah yes I think we kind of hammering
home here is layout is dips forget about
physical pixels layout equals dips
little about that yeah once like I guess
yeah if we go into the next slide one
slight and you know variation on dips
and is when we're talking about text
sizing so and this is very closely
related to dips but and we have to
introduce you know the ability the user
has the ability to scale the text up and
down as a user preference it's really a
climate accessibility feature so you
know some users just need to have larger
text so whenever you're sizing any any
text for your layout so you need to be
using this SP unit the scale independent
pixel and if the users kind of not
change their kind of scale than one SP
and will equal one DP and but you need
to bear in mind that the user can bump
that both up and down so you can I get
like
to scare like what is it like 1.2 X or 1
before exercise if you bunk it up or it
might be slightly smaller so you need to
respect that users you know chosen
chosen setting and scale your units your
text in SPS yeah so that means if you're
if you actually have like two content
blocks right like two pieces of text
that are adjacent you know make sure
that you know the spacing between them
for example scales with the text size
you also want to use SP units for the
like the margins for example generally
we use SP units for like text size
attributes but they're useful in other
cases when you want to make sure be very
cognizant of you know spacing between
texts and things of that is a good way
to test your apps right if you're
worried about you know you want to test
your layouts to the extreme then change
the language to German and put the
scaling feature up to maximum and see
how your how your layout handles it so
we got a flight in Rio novo let's fly
through so do ya
I was going to say they say yeah when we
talk about layout then you wanted to go
about physical pixels but when we're
talking about bitmap assets then you
absolutely need to think in pixels so
you know the only thing that changes
when you go to from you know some like
the zoom to the nexus 10 which has the
same kind of layout size and dips is you
need your assets to be crisp right if
you were just used the exact same assets
from a from an MDP air device on an
xhdpi device then they'll be super
blurry so this is where this and we
introduced this concept of density
buckets
it lets you like nothing about raw
density but kind of group them together
into these kind of illogical densities
here so as we've talked about all along
we have this mdpi bucket or 160 dpi is
our baseline and we're all the first
android devices came out and slowly
that's kind of drifted upwards into
where it arranged now we're xhdpi is
kind of like the norm on most phones and
XX seems to be perhaps coming in and so
the idea here is that if you have an
icon like we show here in the right-hand
column which needs to be fed to by 32
dips on an mdpi device that would
translate into 50 by 30 pixels but on an
xhdpi device that would actually turn
out to be 64 by 64 pixels so you have
complete control over there you know a
pixel perfect icon on an xhdpi device
you can draw it at 64 by 64 and and then
you know the device will pick the right
density version at runtime
and the DPI buckets highlighted in bulb
just quickly here there's sort of the
key density buckets so you should not
generally provide all your assets in
those densities the other ones are sort
of less common but you may potentially
want to provide key assets in those
densities as well it's sort of your call
there especially xx HTTP I feel launcher
icon mm-hmm a lot of people ask can I
just provide the highest density ones
and have a Android you know scale it
down and so forth and that is I mean you
can do there's a slight performance it's
not huge but it's going to be wearable
we're off site and the room is going to
come back to talk about some techniques
you can use to actually you know do this
a little bit more smartly but yeah just
moving for to the next slide and this is
the kind of concept I want to talk about
is a you don't really want to design
your your application you know
specifically around a certain device
because you know the device landscapes
changing all the time it's kind of
giving end up chasing your own tail
so using these techniques of you know
only thinking in depth for layout and
only thinking about density for pics all
assets for bitmap assets is your route
to happiness for you know device future
devices so the example kept on going
back to here is you know if you had
provided a layout for something like the
Motorola Xoom the first generation of
Android tablets came out and which was
like 1280 by 800 and you had provided
and you know xhdpi these kind of high
high density bitmap assets for something
like the Galaxy Nexus all of a sudden
when a device like the Nexus 10 comes
out which you know you've mine I've
heard about you know a year ago when you
did this it'll pick the same layouts as
the Motorola Xoom your pick and you know
the high-density bitmap assets from the
from the phones and put them together
and have this you know you know
optimized looking layout and and clear
assets so it's a really really nice
system to be able to think about these
things to you things separately mm-hmm
moving on really quick pixel grid tips
so when you're doing asset production
this is actually one general tip and you
can kind of tweak this as you see fit
one thing that I generally do is use a
four pixel grid for designing assets and
I start with xhdpi so you can see here
you know starting with xhdpi
lining things up to a four pixel grid
means that you can actually then scale
down to http IM DPI and i'm not sure
about ldpi but probably all dpi as well
and get really really crisp borders so
this is actually something that we do
our system assets so if you look at the
default button asset the kind of the
pressed state for the button you'll
notice that the size of the of the kind
of glow around the core shape is eight
pixels and the reason for that is that
you know the reason it's not seven
pixels or five pixels is that it scales
down really really nicely so there's
just kind of a quick tip if you're doing
asset production you know aligning to a
four pixel grid is really really useful
for scaling down okay so that was it for
units of measure we flew through them
there's they're still you know we're
still over time let's really briefly
talk about design news actually anything
Before we jump into that any kind of
parting thoughts on pixels and dips and
things now yeahit's layouts dips always
easy yeah let's play out some day okay
so design news the first is we actually
have a New York Android designers meetup
coming up next week is the very first
meetup and we're hoping to have you know
multiple of these meetups over the next
few I guess a few months
I don't know how frequently will do it
but definitely something that we're
starting up now this is actually run by
Paul Burke from from the Android
designers Google+ community and so if
you're in New York or the general area
and you're free next Thursday and around
forgot what time at 6:30 or 7:00 p.m.
Eastern then uh you know visit this link
and we'll see you there
that's what it looked like it looks like
we lost Nick oh it looks like we lost
Nick in the Hangout
okay thanks Pete Pete's producing thanks
Pete and the last item in our design
news is the Android UI design kit so
Taylor Lang kind of has this this design
kit that's kind of like a nice starting
point a nice template for doing sorts of
visual designs and if you're interested
in doing this and you're I think I don't
know which devices he has but probably
like you know various devices if you're
kind of interested in getting a nice
easy starting point with a couple of
patterns already you know pre pre
packaged in there and this is a nice
starter kit
I think we're see ourselves twice now
there's Nick this is what we get for
going over time yes so yeah so that's
kind of his updated version of the UI
design kit all right and I think that's
it for the content today any parting
thoughts fellas no Nick is still super
present explain okay well well thanks
again for joining into the design in
action I'm your host Roman Nurik
Adam Kosh and over a man of you we have
Nick butcher who is frozen right now
absolutely thanks guys see you next name
yeah